i've got a very very brief coach's
corner segment in a previous coach's
quarter segment i talked about
three different ways to try to estimate
your total daily energy expenditure
which is always a great place to start
if you're thinking about
putting together a diet whether it's
going to be a weight loss diet a
maintenance diet a weight gain diet you
want to start by getting a calorie
target and figuring out your total daily
energy expenditure is going to be very
very informative for that so i talked
about three different approaches that
you could take you could assume you
could estimate or you could observe and
you could go back to that episode i
think it was the most recent episode
where i walked through those those three
different approaches but now i want to
kind of extend those three different
approaches and talk about
how we would use those to actually set a
calorie target rather than just simply
estimating total daily energy
expenditure so if you want to do the
assume approach this is where we're
making a very
uh
very basic assumption it's not
particularly detailed or nuanced uh for
some people it simply won't work well uh
but you could make an assumption based
on calories uh relative to body weight
so uh you could think of it as being you
know 15 calories per pound of body
weight in many cases is gonna put you
around maintenance and you can think of
that as 15 plus or minus one so like 14
to 16 for a lot of people um and 15
calories per pound is equivalent to 33
kilocalories per kilogram okay and when
i say calories here i'm talking about
kilocalories just to be clear so 15
calories per pound or 33 calories per
kilogram will put you right around
maintenance plus or minus uh you know
that that range i mentioned if you
wanted to push a cut pretty hard you
might go down all the way to about 11
calories per pound
or 24.2 calories per kilogram
physique athletes who you know are kind
of lower on the energy expenditure
spectrum sometimes they'll go down as
low as 10 or even 9
calories per pound for brief periods of
time at the end of their prep it's
brutal it's very low calorie intakes but
i know some people are going to look at
these numbers in bulk and say no i need
way fewer calories if i'm cutting so
for an aggressive cut in my opinion is
usually around 11 but you will sometimes
see instances where to get really really
lean late in the diet you do have to go
below 11.
for a bulk you know moderate bulk might
be up around 17 calories per pound and
aggressive bulk would be a little bit
higher up around 19 calories per pound
again these are all plus or minus one
give or take uh this is a really rough
estimate that we're getting here i we we
posted about this today on instagram and
people already were saying those
estimates don't really work for me uh
and that is not just understandable it's
to be expected you know rough estimates
are going to have areas where they
simply don't work well
for a given individual that's why in
macro factor we don't use this concept
at all this is just kind of the easiest
most straightforward basic way to do it
a more nuanced approach which is
particularly useful if you have no data
about an individual's energy expenditure
or energy intake and body weight changes
over time if you're just starting with a
blank slate we could use the estimate
approach where we would use you know
some type of equation and some type of
activity correction factor to estimate
total daily energy expenditure and then
we would just set the calorie target
based as a percentage of total daily
energy expenditure so um you know we
talked about the harris benedict uh
equation is pretty good for for uh
people who don't do resistance training
i think the cunningham equation is great
for people who do lift weights and do
resistance training but you want to use
one of the very common uh estimation
equations and then you want to use the
activity correction factors i think r's
are better than the standard because the
standard ones
kind of don't make sense i'm not saying
ours are perfect either i mean like you
know it's hard to try to do an activity
correction factor one of the things that
makes it difficult to make them perfect
is the fact that uh exercise doesn't
affect the total data energy we should
have put out a table and every cell on
the table just says zero don't worry
about it
so anyway you're going to get your total
daily energy expenditure estimate if you
want to do an aggressive cut you might
be eating like 60 to 70 percent of
estimated total daily energy expenditure
moderate cut will probably be about 80
to 90 percent so you'll be in a 10 20
deficit maintenance obviously is just
100
moderate bulk would be up around 105 to
110 percent and then an aggressive bulk
you'd be eating 115 to and twenty
percent of your estimated total daily
energy expenditure some people might
think uh you know oh i could push harder
than that if i'm bulk i could go higher
and that's ultimately going to depend on
what kind of a hurry you're in um you
know how much adipose tissue you're
comfortable gaining during that muscle
gaining phase and also what your
potential for muscle gain is you know
people who have really great muscle
building genetics who are early in their
lifting career they probably can get
away with pushing some pretty serious
caloric surpluses because they've got a
whole bunch of capacity to add muscle
quickly and adding muscle quickly is a
process that requires a lot of energy
now the third approach is observe and
you know when we talked about total
daily energy expenditure we talked about
observing your energy intake changes in
body weight using that to make
inferences about changes in total daily
energy expenditure and the total
energy content of one's body you know
based on changes in in body composition
so with the observe approach
it's the same kind of deal we want to be
watching changes in body weight over
time and using that to guide whether or
not we need to change our calorie target
so um you know if you are using this
observe approach what you're doing is
tracking your calorie target tracking
changes in body weight and composition
and then basically titrating your
calorie intake from there aiming for a
particular rate of weight change whether
it's weight loss or weight gain so if
you're on a pretty aggressive cut you
might be losing body weight at over one
percent of body weight per week uh you
know one one and a half
usually that's about where you're going
to find things if you're go if you start
getting over too far over
one and a half percent of body weight
per week it starts to get pretty
aggressive it's it's not a particularly
enjoyable process there
moderate cut is usually 0.25 to 1 of
body weight loss per week maintenance
obviously is just keeping body weight
pretty stable a moderate bulk you might
be looking to gain 0.1 to 0.25 percent
of body weight per week and with an
aggressive bulk you might be gaining
over 0.25 percent of body weight per
week so there are kind of the three
different approaches
uh extending those from estimating total
daily energy expenditure taking it a
step further and seeing how those would
ultimately lead to
you know recommendations in terms of a
calorie target for a variety of
different goals
and you know whether you choose between
a moderate or a more aggressive cut a
moderate or a more aggressive bulk a lot
of contextual factors that go into that
these uh general guidelines don't
necessarily work perfectly for everyone
especially the first couple approaches
uh have some limitations where there are
people who just are on the higher or
lower end of the spectrum for total
daily energy expenditure there are
people for whom uh some of those
estimation equations don't work
perfectly well especially like
catch the the harris benedict and
cunningham ones i think are kind of the
cream of the crop but there are some
ones that are commonly used that
for certain uh for certain uh
populations they just don't work
particularly well so these are to try to
get within the ballpark but the observe
approach where you're actually making
changes based on changes in body weight
over time it is a really tried and true
method to make sure that you're keeping
on track and so obviously with macro
factor when we have you know changes in
body weight we've got all your daily
caloric intakes we're able to update
those calorie targets on the fly that's
really the basis of how we do it